success success success define success
for yourself define success success
define success for yourself success
hello believe nation today I want you to
learn how to define success for yourself
and as always guys if you are watching
this video if you hear something that
really inspires you please leave it in
the comments below
but quotes around it other people can be
inspired as well enjoy I think that
financial success is not successful you
know to me and when people say for
example I showed Pan's Labyrinth and
somebody said why don't you take out the
violence and it was very well-meaning
why don't you take out the violence so
you can reach a wider audience that's
because I don't know why not wider
audience I want the audience for the
movie each movie has an audience that's
it it's not gonna get more or less if
you with it have you amputated if you
[ __ ] it that's all you do you know
people dream of a bigger audience and I
go well you know yeah but is it the
movie if in order to make more people
happy the you know Cinderella doesn't
get the prince at the end I don't know
it's not it's not the same tale you know
it's as much as I like that there's many
films of the Renaissance of animation I
can't every time I see the Little
Mermaid I think but she dies in the in
the book she dies at the end that's what
made it beautiful that the Prince was
ultimately so stupid and I understand
they are reaching a wider audience but
he said the tale that has Christian
Andersen wrote no way it's a different
movie it's a different tale so if you're
asking me was Little Mermaid successful
as a film I say it was but it wasn't
the tail it's a great I love those films
I really think they're beautiful
constructed but it's not the tail
so Pan's Labyrinth without the violence
it is not Pan's Labyrinth
is I don't know
it's a fantasy like Harry Potter or
Narnia or any other senses of self
greatness is a different definition of
different people greatness to me is when
I land that fakie half-caf hill and my
skateboarder session greatness is the
song I recorded last week somebody might
not find that great but it's great to me
and that's all that matters
with the Gothic in my head as long as I
like it that's all that matters
greatness to me is finally getting my
video on MTV it's on there now and I'm
I'm happy I finally got my stuff MTV
some people might think that's selling
out or whatever but I don't really give
a that's great to me I'm proud of myself
I've been one that since I was seven
years old and I finally got that hard
work paid the [ __ ] off at the end of our
session yesterday you said thank you to
Scott for reviving my career and I don't
know if that's ingest because I've never
had the impression that you you're
desperate for box office but that you
cannot aim for it absolutely it's been
my it's been the thrust of my of my
interests since day one when I was about
19 yeah so I care about 20 years of
failures will do that to you but on a
different level why do you say that and
how do you feel when you choose a role
that ends up satisfying you that this
one clearly did well you know for me
with every character that you play you
know as long as you've reached that
you've arrived at that place where you
believe is is the right place to be for
the character and if you feel that
you've done service to the to the
director to yourself to the author then
to me to me that's a success it
box office is kind of you know that's
something else that's not certainly none
of my business you know I mean once it
won't sound wraps on a film it's just to
say goodbye to the character and then
move forward everyone in this room wants
to make it but I question how you would
recognize making it what is making it
well what do you want to be who you in
here wants a record deal would it be
nice to ever be nice have a record deal
right we want a record deal okay well
what does a record deal look like how
what is making it look like who do you
want to sell a million copies two
million copies well okay let's say
selling two million copies is like
selling talent 10 million copies 10
years ago so let's say you say to
yourself my expectation is that I want
to be an artist and I wanted to put
records out and I want to sell millions
of copies if that's their expectation
great then you sort of skip straight to
another questionnaire you know okay if
you answered yes to do I want to be a
pop star do I want to make music for as
many people as possible now you have to
sort of change your game to fit the
expectation you now have to wonder about
is your song shorter than four minutes
do you get to your core as fast enough
these are these are the things you have
to absolutely do and you also have to
compromise and you also have to play the
game you know and by defining grant
expect ations
if you decide that you want to be a pop
star that's not a dirty word it just
means pop just means popular Frank
Sinatra was a pop star
Jimi Hendrix was a pop star lots of
people were pop stars what kind of pop
star lots people with jazz musicians
what kind of jazz musician be you can
define the genre any way you want so if
you said you want to be a pop star then
you have to look at your songs there's
also people here who are a little
dishonest about what they really want to
be and I think if you want to be famous
if you want to make music for as many
people as possible just come out and say
it
don't say I want to be in D I'm just
gonna be an independent artist and
really secretly wish that you wanted to
be a pop star
because from the from them from the very
beginning it's disingenuous there's
nothing wrong with saying I want to play
for as many people as possible without
compromising the things that I have to
be as an artist and that's what I've
done so many music doesn't come into the
studio when I'm making a record but I
also know what's going to be a hit or
what stands the chance of being a hit
and what just doesn't and it's a level
of honesty with yourself that you have
to have before you hand your music out
to anybody else so that's sort of what I
want to say about expectations if you
only recognize success as a record deal
and a big fat Publishers Clearing House
oversized Tiger Woods check and a dinner
and then going to the top of the roof
and screaming I made most of you will be
stunning failures if you had to give
someone who's recently graduating from
our program a piece of advice what would
you say I would say to learn and to
execute on your unique vision define
success for yourself figure out what
that means to you don't get taken over
by the world's definition of success or
your families or what your friends are
doing or what anyone says that equals
success once you can get clear on that
vision then you need to create a plan to
make that come to life and to prioritize
I think one of the biggest tragedies of
our time is I hear so many people from
every walk of life health coaches all
over feeling so overwhelmed and
overworked and there's so much that they
can do that they feel paralyzed well I
don't know what to do first or what how
do I make all of this happen and I think
that we all need to take a few steps
back and start to get clear on our own
vision for success and then actually
prioritize making that come to life
because then it gives you such clarity
and such freedom and all of that static
and the overwhelm starts to fall away I
define success two ways one what I do
here at the firm the impact that I
create my clients the impact that I
create for the partnership now the new
role that I have the legacy that I leave
that is one way that I will define
success you know I'm not a great
cricketer
I love cricket I wish I was as good as
such and something do
I'm not this is my life's work what I do
here is my life's work it will define me
and the second thing that will define me
is what my 11 year old son thinks of me
when he becomes a man these are the two
things that define success for me and in
that is a little bit of a conundrum
because I love what I do it is as I said
my life's work I love my son more than I
love myself and there is a constant tug
there isn't enough hours in the day to
be able to do both extremely well and so
that is my challenge how do you define
success for you what is success to you
I guess success is when is when people
are listening and and there's some
measurable change in in consciousness
worldwide even if it's even if the
needle barely moves you know I think
that if you're if you're communicating
ideas and telling stories if the
feedback if the feedback is that those
that those seeds are landing on fertile
soil that's that success I think you
know I I would say I felt that even more
with with Avatar than with Titanic
Titanic we definitely moved people for a
couple of hours and and they cried and
and then they left and that was that you
know avatar is a different story because
it lingered with them and and you know
dare I say maybe even to some tiny tiny
degree may influence their their
perspective on how we're behaving with
respect to the natural world and
basically the you know the destruction
that were causing define success for
yourself you already liked that one
define success for yourself but check
this out
I'm in South of New Orleans a few years
ago when I went to a voodoo shop and
they had this this wooden partition
against the wall at these columns and in
these columns were all these vials of
these magic potions right and the
headings above each potion defining what
they would give you were things like
fertility health family legal health
energy forgiveness money hmm guess which
column was empty
Monday first admit it
money's keen today it's what make the
work makes the world go round it is
success the more we have the more
successful we are right now I would
argue that our cultural values have even
been financialized financialized
humility is not in vogue anymore it's
too passive
it's a get-rich-quick on the Internet
riches 15 minutes of fame world that we
live in and we see it every day but we
all want to succeed right so the
question that we've got to ask ourselves
is what success is to us what success is
to you is it more money that's fine I
got nothing against money I don't maybe
it's a healthy family maybe it's a happy
marriage maybe it's to help others to be
famous to be spiritually sound to leave
the world a little bit better place than
you found it
continue to ask yourself that question
now your answer may change over time and
that's fine but do yourself this favor
whatever your answer is don't choose
anything that will jeopardize your soul
prioritize who you are who you want to
be and don't spend time with anything
that antagonizes your character don't
drink the kool-aid mmm it tastes sweet
but you will get cavities tomorrow
all right life is not a popularity
contest be brave take the hill but first
answer that question
what's my hill so me how do i how do i
define success for me myself well for me
it's a measurement of five things we got
fatherhood
we got being a good husband we got my
health mind body and spirit we've got
career and we got friendships these are
what's important to me in my life right
now so I try to measure these five
things each day I check in with them I
like to see whether or not I'm in the
the debit section or the credit section
with each one a man in the red or I'm in
the black you follow for instance
sometimes say my career's rolling all
right it's way up here in the black but
I see how my relationship with my wife
maybe you could use a little bit more my
attention I got to pick up the slack on
being a better husband get that one out
of the red or say my spiritual health
could use some maintenance it's down
here but a man my friendships in my
social life they're in high gear right I
got to recalibrate checks and balances I
got to go to church remember to say
thank you more often something but I got
to take the tally because I want to keep
all five in healthy shape and I know
that if I don't take care of them if I
don't keep up maintenance on them one of
them is going to get weak man it's going
to dip too deep into the debit section
it's gonna go bankrupt it's gonna get
sick die even so first we have to define
success for ourselves and then we have
to put in the work to maintain it take
that daily tally tend our garden keep
the things that are important to us in
good shape I mean let's admit it
we've all got two wolves in us a good
one and a bad and they both want to eat
the best I can tell we just got a feed
that good one a little more than the
other one
one thing I believe is it's really
important to define your own success
it's really important to decide yourself
what success looks like as opposed to
letting someone else impose their
definition of success upon you so
whenever you begin a big project if
you're doing something on your own if
you're starting a business or a blog or
going back to school or even if it's an
exercise program whatever it is you know
you have your own definition of success
I need to make sure that everybody knows
success is not money right money drives
you up to your problems and Limousine
right so success is sometimes being a
great parent a greater dedicating
yourself to your faith there are so many
people that don't necessarily have
millions and millions and they're
happier than many of us ever will be
here so I don't want to you know over
push the fact of money is success
because that's not the case thank you
guys so much for watching I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
what clip resonated the most with you
what are you going to immediately apply
to your life or to your business leave
it down in the comments below I'm also
super curious how do you define success
for
yourself what does that look like for
you leave in the comments I'm going to
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to bleed OD thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and making that fun
YouTube tribute video I really really
really appreciate the effort and the
love
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
[Music]